welcome back everybody before we go I
have one more inspiring story from
social media to share this is what I'm
liking
[Applause]
so June is National cancer survivor
month nearly 17 million people in the
U.S are cancer survivors that includes
anyone currently battling the disease as
well so if you're fighting cancer right
now you are a Survivor I want to
introduce you to one cancer survivor
with an inspiring message for everybody
say hello to Chris Ann who watches on
NBC4 Los Angeles so chrisanne you are
welcome to the show first of all hello
thank you you are you are battling
cancer as we speak is this right yeah I
was diagnosed about two years ago
um and I've been fighting it every day
since then I'm a single mom so it's a
little bit tough for me because I have
stage four and metastatic breast cancer
but I go in every three weeks and I get
my treatment and I think as every
Survivor knows you just keep moving
forward you don't stop you keep moving
and I think I can speak for all of us
when I say that we're so grateful to be
having continued treatment and for all
of the doctors and the nurses and the
hospital staff that help us get through
this you know cancer cancer changes you
in every possible way it makes you know
beyond a shadow of a doubt what's really
important in life and for me that's the
amazing network of support that I have
that helps me get through it and makes
me grateful for every day that I'm given
wow well you discovered something on
this journey that's helped what is that
I think really just to enjoy your life
every day right right now right this
very minute for me I enjoyed Ted lasso
the show Happy it fills me with such Joy
I mean it's it's really ultimately about
kindness and cancer teaches you about
kindness I even heard from some of the
cast members they sent me get well and
encouragement videos and uh were just
completely amazing but what I think I
want to say
and remind everybody is that cancer
touches all of us you know so lend your
support and celebrate the people who are
fighting this battle right now whether
it's somebody you know with cancer or a
healthcare professional that is helping
somebody battle cancer give them your
celebration and support I mean we're
gonna win this fight but we would love
your support too absolutely thank you so
much Chris and for sharing your story
with us I'm a single Mama as well I
can't imagine all that's on your plate
right now so God bless you you're in my
prayers you're my thoughts you're in all
of our thoughts I'm liking your post
right now right
thank you
and that's not all Chris and our Susan
long partner pilot pin makers of G2 the
go-to pin of the Kelly Clarkson show
want to celebrate Unstoppable people
just like you ma'am so they're going to
give you a thousand dollars how does
that sound
thank you though that's so great I
really absolutely and I have to say I
love your rock and roll hair I just
couldn't let you leave without me
talking about Chopin care it's so cute
so thank you so much Chris Anne and
thank you to all of our guests this hour
Eva Longoria Annie Gonzalez and Colton
Dixon y'all have a great day and if it's
not try and change it
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
guys I'm going
[Music]